this film is about meditation
and um
like any art
like any art uh
drawing
playing an instrument
walking mountain climbing
all the things that you can think about
that you may even call hobbies
if you do it regular enough
then it's not
because the more you do it the better
you get the more economical you perhaps
will get
the more relaxed you'll get
and uh
in time over many years with the right
tuition
from those who have
walked the path before
you will also
experience
many things that perhaps you can pass on
i'd like to pass on the
things that i've found in meditation
and perhaps you'd like to
think about them
i rarely ever recommend anybody or say
names
when i do i think it's because it's an
important thing
i was talking to my friend who does
aikido miles kessler
he resides in israel at the moment
originally from america
went to japan studies did a martial art
aikido
some of you may know and
then for a break
he started going to burma where he would
study
for months on end
meditation
and it sounds
did like every time he would then come
on to europe and
teach
he would start my house and i was
fortunate enough to have a dojo we call
it the dojo
training place
where he would teach
and
in the early days when i asked him oh
would you teach meditation he said
rather not i'm still studying
this went on year after year after year
i i'd asked him the same question it was
as if
he didn't feel comfortable
perhaps he'll explain it differently but
he didn't feel comfortable then
to teach it
i believe i got him to talk about it
once
and that's all
but since then he's
like all of us grown older
and he's found a great deal in
sharing his knowledge
so if if i'd like to recommend you to
anybody i just touch the surface and
tell you about
my meditation my thoughts on it
and how i do it
he goes into great depth
and he does
seminars
courses
you can do a year or two year programmes
with him
and anybody who's serious
like the serious musician the serious
walker
the serious martial artist i recommend
you
seek him out
miles kessler
and you'll find that he offers a great
deal
all i can do is what i'm going to do
today and let's talk about a few things
i've tried to frame this there's a door
here
a painted wall
a bureau
there's an object
computer object here
there's a very small
speaker
green speaker
now why am i telling you all this detail
silver door handle
pane of glass
you may see something else you may see
behind here there's a
small i just train
it it's a doorstop
the carpet i'm sitting on a meditation
store you may not just see the brown
pieces around it
why am i going to the trouble of
explaining all this to you
it's because your brain the ego mind
it just will not let you settle
so anybody who wants to start doing
meditation
where's my hands oh he's moving his
thumbs perhaps he's
conscious
of um
being under pressure in front of the
camera perhaps he's doing it as a
nervous thing
why is he doing it why don't he just
keep his hands still why is that hand
over that hand why is that hand over
that hand
there's many answers
to all your questions
but what i why i've just described each
item is because
as you are watching me your mind will be
bouncing looking at all these different
things all these
immaterial things but your mind will try
to capture your attention
and look at it
is it what wood that is
well it's oak actually but
so i'm trying to alleviate
the doors i've no idea
but they're supposed to be oak
i'm telling you as much information i
can so we can get it out of the way
once we get all that out of the way
and all the questions your mind's asking
it's a little bit like your mind's a
computer
and like a computer in the background
there'll be lots of processes going on
that you're not perhaps looking at now
perhaps you'd have some pages open
perhaps you didn't if any page is open
but the computer has a lot of apps to
keep that satisfied so it's
it opens them when the computer
naturally opens up
you might not be using them or even
asking them to perform
but the computer has been instructed
in the beginning
to open them
and keep them running in the background
so your mind is
in the background working out
all these different things it might even
be working
is it light is it too dark does he need
more light should he do this should he
do that
i hope you're following me and i hope
you're understanding what i'm talking
about
so i've tried to limit
what i'm giving your wayne
to play tricks
with
shadows in the background everything
he could do it better and if he'd done
this have he done that
okay so i think i've said enough about
that
the best thing
we're in 2022
and
there's a worldwide pandemic
i normally wouldn't say the dates of the
years and things like this but it's
quite important time at the moment
because a lot of people
even if they say oh i'm not worried
about it
is it
like running one of those apps in the
background
do you find you're a little bit snappier
with people
are you under a bit oppression but don't
really know why because in general
you're quite happy
you need to get to know about all these
things that may be gone in the
background that you haven't thought of
i do full routine if i'm going to sit
like this and do meditation i normally
like to do it for 15-20 minutes
i'm not a long meditator i don't sit for
an hour
that's me that's my makeup
i'm happy after
20 minutes
on my car for now
it depends on the day and it depends on
the calmness
i always make sure i clean my teeth i
try to shower first
go to the toilet
do as many things to clear my body
i'm not the best of people for
eating
vegan or anything like that
i do eat chicken
but i try to do my best so that's all we
can ask you to do so please do your best
so now for the meditation today
when i was a young boy
and i'm sure only older people will know
about this
we used to have a normal hair comb a
plastic cone
and there used to be some toilet paper
called zell toilet paper
and again i don't know if you can still
get it
but it's the same as tracing paper
but you would get a pencil and you would
rub the lead against an object that was
underneath the tracing paper
and an
outline would come out
so it's a very sort of shiny
paper
and it was the best paper for this job
and you would fold a piece of this
toilet paper and a comb
sand isn't it now we want an xbox
but the things that we were happy with
playing
would be something as simple as this
we would fold the cell toilet paper over
the cone
and we would put it near our mouth and
go
and it made this wonderful vibrating
sound
and of course
now i don't need a cone die
and i don't even know you can still get
zel toilet paper that my age why would i
but i can but i still like making the
sound
one
it takes my mind off
my daily worries
two
i'm stimulating and vibrating my lips
and the mouth is a very important
thing
we don't realize how many muscles and
senses
nerve endings are in our mouth
perhaps
exercise first
stretch the jaw
make sure the neck
is soft if it's tense massage it
you don't have to do all this i'm just
giving you all this information so the
brain has got something to consider
so sometimes i do this sometimes i don't
it's just that
it's like
to paint a picture you need to get out
your paints your brushes your easel your
paper
you know everything needs preparation
don't think that you can just sit
anywhere
and just be ready to meditate
of course you can when you're an
experienced meditator but you can't when
you're starting out perhaps for the
first few years
okay i'm going to decide to die i don't
want my wife or left i want my left over
my right that's just my mind's telling
me what i want i'm going to
relax my shoulders make sure i'm sitting
up straight
i'm going to close my eyes softly not
quickly at all
i will enjoy the outward breaths
they're coming in through my nose going
out through my mouth
the main word here
is enjoying them
enjoy them
enjoy them coming in through the nose
through the nostrils
feel them rushing
by the sides
feel it going all the way up to the top
enjoy the opening of the mouth slightly
and letting it go
don't make a big thing of it just
enjoy if your lips need
the wetting then wet them
enjoy
now when you're ready
we're going to do my comb and sound
paper vibration
so i close my eyes softly
i breathe in
through the nostrils i breathe out
through the mouth
i should keep breathing through the
nostrils
[Music]
but the mouth i will purposely make the
vibration
[Music]
come on
so i don't bore you with my vibration
but
i suggest that you do this for you i
mean you never clock if you so wish to
be
precise about time have a clock and
tell yourself that you'll do it for
five or ten minutes
five minutes perhaps start but if you
want to carry on after five minutes
because you're enjoying it
then you can
in my early days i would cheat i would
have my eyes closed
and i'd purchase half
open and i just i wouldn't move my head
but i'm moving for the camera i went
halfway while i just look at the clock
and then slowly close it again i
wouldn't open both eyes
i know it's cheap but i get the
information i want
and i i'm also not disturbing myself too
much
the vibrations coming all the way from
the center all the way
it's not just coming out the center
the car's just gone by
and that was vibrating as he accelerated
a boy racer with his exhaust
you may have heard it on the film
that wasn't me
so good luck in your
search and i hope it helps it's another
form of meditation
thank you for your time